70 MILLION! SEVENTY! OH YEAH!!!!
THIS IS EPIC, AND OBAMA
IS GONE
Highlight of my carrer. Highlight of everything.
Who woulda thought, 8 years later
all you needed was an Indian Channel and you can complete ANYTHING. Thank you guys so much!
we made history yet again. Guess what I'm doing today guys?
That's right. We're reviewing memes yet again
It's nice to see you know that a channel finally has the amount of subscribers
that reflect the content
Finally a channel that lives up to his subscriber count
"Getting him to 70 million was nothing. Come on. Let's make this happen
Can we start YouTube rewind with PewDiePie cla👏pping👏 and saying...
👏👏
YEAR.
REVIEW
Oh, how about that a funny original idea for you to rewind. I'm sure they're gonna incorporate that!
OF C O U R S E! THEY ARE. Yeah, that's definitely going to happen. I can't wait for you to rewind.
T- Series gains 9000 subscribers in-
Wait, what?
proving they use..what?
So, you had 91 thousand and he went to..whoa
Is that real? When did this happen? How do you get nine thousand subscribers?
I mean, I guess it could-it could be fake, but I don't know.
How do you get nine thousand subscribers like that?
"Me checking every day to make sure I wasn't automatically subscribed-"
-to T series."
69696969
Takeshi Six Nine, please. Stop pretending like you don't want to host Meme Review.
Alright, it's not like you have anything better to do.
Takeshi Six Nine? I'm calling you out
B   I   G      T  I   M  E
IT'S   T I M E.
👏👏
We need you to review Takeshi Six Nine memes.
It's for the greater good of the planet.
do you not care about the E N V I R O N M E N T
Shake my head shaking and crying right now. I knew it Takeshi step up and man up man
This could be very epic...EpicGames. It's time to combine forces Felix.
what if EpicGames teamed up with PewDiePie to defeat t-series by creating a custom Felix Fortnite skin and the only way you can get
The skin is by subscribing to PewDiePie. YES !
Yes, of course
Why wouldn't Epic Games
agree to do that with me after me trolling them for six month that I don't want to play Fortnite
Even though I actually don't care I literally--the only reason I don't like Fortnite's because it's so popular
I'm sure it's a great game. Actually Epic Games. that would be epic.
Listen anyone willing to extend their helping hand
I'll take it. I need all the help I can need, cause I know that together we are strong.
Oh my god
Yeah, people have been tweeting this to me and-legit, when I saw it the first time, first of all
we have so many goddamn spiders in that office. Okay, there's so many spiders. I have to kill one at least every single day
They're nesting they're conspiring against me. I swear to God if they were T-series' CIA bots
I wouldn't be surprised
Okay
but I saw it and I'm like that's
obviously just like a little bit of, I don't know , string coming out and then I check the shirt and I'm like, oh no
Oh nO, WHAT IF IT'S STILL ON ME!? It could be anywhere. This is not epic, man
My first meme be kind please. He protecc, he attacc, but most importantly...
he takes trolly bacc
*claps*
That's right everybody what can I say I'm doing my part
I'M DOING MY PART
That's right, I do take my trolley back and you best do as well
This stupid photo--me and Marzia saw the guy taking a photo of us. We were both laughing at him.
I didn't think the photo would come out
Look what you've done
People treat me like I'm some ancient being that.
I'm some metaphysical being that just exists on the Internet and you know
God forbid I buy groceries. What, eh, what is this now? jUSt sToP.
this is um,
This is actually bullying
God, damn it
I'M NOT A VIRGIN!!!
Ten subs in two years.
five mil in six months.
three mil in 30 days
It's actually more
9000 in ONE SECOND.
👏👏👏👏
I mean, explain that. someone explain that please I hope he does know we are two completely different nations
Bangladesh promotes PewDiePie.
PewDiePie : Thanks Indian for the support
There's been so many articles about this. Bangladesh Backs PewDiePie
Battle with T series. Despite him now not realising  it's a country
I KNOW it's a country. Come on, of course Bangladesh
It's a place where Bangladesh where they have the the 11 hour flight
Bangladesh which loves cricket.
It the largest Bay in the entire world
How could I not know that C O M E  O N. the fifth most populous country in Asia get out of here, of course
I know about Bangladesh you had a freaking tiger. As your country's national ahn- animal. How freaking cool is that Bungladesh?
Thank you for your service. VERY cool. Of course, I know Blangladesh.Get out of here.
Let's get this epic victory royale guys
Start YouTube rewind with PewDiePie clapping saying new hero there this again
It's not gonna happen. Okay, don't worry about it. Dr. Phil. We have a situation here. I'm white. I'm black
I'm poppy Harlow. Well, one of them is lying
I mean two of them is like, okay
I make these videos making fun of these people for having distorted worldviews. Here  I am talking about conspiracy theories
Thinking I'm a female news anchor
Population: we are starving. Soviet Union: sends dog to space
population *am i just a joke to you??*
How does this make it in here? that relatable moment when your country sends a dog to space.
YouTube algorithm 100
Pewdiepie sucks and is gay, read description. I'm not a PewDiePie hater
I'm a bro But I am a new youtuber so I figured this would be a good way to get views. Please understand.
I mean pretty much you got it right there
Feel free to call me suck some gay at any time for views III give you the big suction gay pass
You geographyn't and you lose
Some thinks he is the best youtuber
Others think he is the best youtuber BUT deep down
We all know that Bangladesh is not inside of India.
I know that ! I know that ! Stop it !
It's right next to it that
This sub right now Peak comedy Pewdiepie goes outside LMAO my friends saw Pewdiepie
Literally literally, it's so crazy. He exists outside in the world. L I T E R A L L Y
WTF I am fricking out right now Pewdiepie is a person.
classic 9 years old
Pewdiepie does normal human being stuff. 9 year old: uh
what?! he's not reviewing memes, what are you doing? I get that question all the time. What are you doing here? I'm buying GROceries
Why the fricc are you here? 70 million? you god damn right the holy Oh God
Sorry guys. I only get one 9/11 joke a year. Lets just move on as quickly as possible
I have a restaurant in Mexico. I'm doing my part Pewds
Thank You Mexico, Very cool
Can I do a trump reference when I talk about Mexico?
I can't tell anyway. Thank you. facts don't care about your memes
It has to be a pewdiepie related meme to post it on PewdiepieSubmissions
Where is that written ?
In the name PewdiepieSubmission.Wow. Thank you Ben Shapiro
if this video gets 300,000 I will do a tik-tok video.
Did I actually say that. I can't tell anymore?
Because you guys fake or danker every one of them time to create a TikTok account
Haha, like so long. It's about time. We have someone else be most subscribe [EVERYONE disliked that]
[eVeRYonE] [ elxcnnjdncjdnjnjdnx]
It's okay she was nice afterwards. Okay. She turned around she realized
Afterwards it was an afterthought. That was necessary. I'm doing my part. Hello. My real name is Amanda
I'm 21 female (but women don't exist) and really bored looking for someone to talk to
How old are you 9 subscribe to PewDiePie. (real legend) Thank you very much
I mean, I hope this says, you know convince you to subscribe to th e channel Our Hero Everybody Oh goddammit
Oh no laughing at girls saying capital of England is Russia
Thinks Bangladesh is a city in India
You know what I just said it as a joke (mhm sure), okay, it was just a meme guys (don't get so shook lads)
Please someone made a wallpaper showing the battle wallpaper engine. Wait, is this real? Okay?
Why did I have to be the small one? You clearly got this all wrong. (no, t-series is the B E S T) Wait, I got it
I can I'm gonna download this that's cool. That's really sick. Damn. You guys are really creative. big props man it syncs
So well, what is this? There's so much think you have been one when I'm through with you. We're gonna be completely fucking big
Let me serve your bitch lasagna, ohHOHOHO. (THIS IS AN EPIK BOP)
yEAH HAHAHA
Oh yeah Grandayy did this. I saw this, so good (THIS VIDEO MADE ME LOSE NO NUT NOVEMBER!!)
The beat is good, man
Alright, i'm gonna leave that. Link in the description, check it out. Grandayy what an angel
(lies, here's link: t9dDn-N5ccA)
Absolute mad lad. Thank you very much
Everybody was so preoccupied with the 6-9 6-9 6-9 6-9 that we forgot how Pewds is actually about to be the first
Channel to pass a category in subs. Damn. Did I happen already? SCREW YOU YouTube movies!
Wait, is there any any other YouTube category YouTube Sports?
YouTube sports, huh? I'm coming for you YouTube sports. You got nothing. You're no one. You're LOSER. Hi
What is your name
Her: Monica ( DOKI DOKIIIIIII LMAO PLEASE KILL ME)
Me:
Hey mONICA (wide eyes)
whoa
Look at that that's sick
that's an amazing fanart of Brad and Marzia inside.
Oh
That's great
on sleepy Maodraws. Thank you. That's awesome. I'm Jesus, but I think you could already tell
so everyone I have an announcement to make
stop bullying (🙏💦)
No, I'm just kidding what I actually need to tell you about something very serious. It's about PewDiePie you see
PewDiePie needs your help in the war against T series. (yes. that's right) We don't want India taking over YouTube
Okay, I watch his Christian YouTube channel every day *nO*. And you should too
so what I need you to do is sMASH subscribe to PewDiePie's channel or
You know where you're going (oh no) I'm gonna watch some 👏👏 meme review hope to see you guys well
Most of you guys hopefully not soon
Thank you Jesus very cool we have Jesus still on our side
Absolutely incredible. This is a trap. That's a trap. It's plainly not showed that she's a gamer
Okay, I guess I was wrong you know what I've learned my lesson here never judge people (nEvEr JuDgE a BoOk bY iT's CoVeR)
But she's not a video game, okay
I know that for a fact she's not a video game prove me that there is so many memes this week
Honestly, the reddit is like bigger than it's ever been
*PEWDS LOOSES HIS DAMN MIND*
Wow, I seriously need to make like a two part two just to go through it honestly, thank you guys 70 million times
You know when Jake Paul came out with this video. I had just moved out of my office
I had taken a lot of I took a lot of decisions to kind of scale date down what I'm doing
Just get back to the roots and do what I actually enjoy doing and I felt really weird at the time
I didn't know what I was doing and you know, you see all these people
Coming out of nowhere as well. I honestly thought like okay this is it for me
But whatever at least I'll do what I'm doing, but to see now all the undying support that I'll be getting on this channel
I'm so lucky to be in this position. I really am so don't think I'm taking it for granted. I really appreciate it!
That's it, though. That's all the butter you're getting. Bye!
*smash that subscribe button!* *subtitles by forevarockzz and eva*
Ayo maika was here spicing up the captions lmaoo (also alicia here too, being a tryhard loser kid.
Also hello, I fixed some stuff. Subscribe to Ok So Basically for content you definitely don't want.
*next goal-69696969Million Subscriber* (subscribe to alicia's tiktok - @cooldet69. this is not a plug i promise)